the story starts with Toma a level zero
expert talking with misaka Makoto a
level 5 esper on how they can stop
accelerator the number one and the
strongest esper from killing the Koto
clones 20 000 times over and over so he
reached the level six after they chat
the main man runs to stop accelerator
and save the sisters meanwhile in the
railway cargo holding area misaka 10 032
is walking along the railroad until
she's called by a familiar voice she
looks up and see accelerator sitting on
top of a shipping container where he
confirms that the Clone before him is
his next victim before starting the
experiment masaka 10 032 suggests to
accelerator that to say the password to
confirm his participation in the
experiment this irritates accelerator
somewhat that least simply states that
he really doesn't need to confirm
anything because it's an experiment that
is trying to make him stronger
accelerator complements mizaka 10 032
for being calm even though she knows
what situation she is in he then tells
her to use her brain the misaka 10 000
and 32 does not understand and stay
States the current time before the
experiment begins misaka asks why he
wants more power even though he is
already the strongest esper in Academy
City a position where no one can reach
him accelerator says that the only
reason people know that he is the
strongest is because people fought him
and lost he says that to her that kind
of strongest is not enough and strives
something beyond that a power that once
acquired by him that challenging him
would be a sin accelerator jumps off of
the container and lands in front of
misaka 10032 she puts on her goggles and
confirms that the experiment will now
begin meanwhile Tomah is hastily trying
to get to accelerator's location leaving
Makoto and the cat on the bridge back in
the cargo area the experiment begins and
accelerator charges back in the bridge
the cat in Makoto's arms becomes
restless due to her electromagnetic
field she recalls on how Toma instructed
her not to interfere in his battle
against accelerator as it is crucial for
him to level zero to be accelerator to
level five Mikoto understands that she
won't be able to do anything if she goes
there however she runs towards
accelerator's location as she can't just
leave things be and do nothing at all
Tomah finally arrives outside the
railway cargo holding area and hears the
sound of battle inside
in battle misaka 10 032 jumps up and
attacks accelerator with her electric
power predictably the attack has no
effect on accelerator the battle
continues with mizaka 10 032
continuously attacking accelerator with
her electric attacks to no effect
accelerator comments on her buying some
time and says that nothing will change
the battle comes into a slight lull as
accelerator tries to catch his breath he
looks up and sees that mizaka 10 032 is
on top of shipping container commenting
on how windless the night is
accelerators suddenly smell something in
the air and realizes that misaka 10 032
is using her powers to break up the
oxygen and create ozone in their
Battleground and making him run out of
air accelerator is rather impressed by
her Ingenuity though he says that her
plan will fail if he catches up to her
and charges towards her she catches to
her and indicates that he changed the
vectors of his feet before punching her
misaka 10 000 and 32's Body Rolls a few
feet away from accelerator before
stopping she's obviously in pain and is
unable to get up however accelerator's
figure looms over her body accelerator
asks her if she knows of a way of
beating an opponent without punching
them he kicks in the stomach and says
that the answer is by touching the
person's body and change the vector of
the opposing momentum he keeps on
kicking misaka 10 0 32 until he notices
something Toma has arrived
Tomah orders accelerator to get away
from misaka 10032 much to accelerators
Amusement accelerator is exasperated
that he has to kill a civilian in order
to keep the experiment a secret Tomah
however tells him to shut up and orders
him once again to get away from misaka
10 032 that was surprised that this
accelerator demonstrates his power to
Toma by kicking a small rock and
destroying a tower even then coma does
not flinch at the sight of his power
accelerator becomes Intrigue at the
sight of toma's fearlessness Toma moves
towards accelerator however misaka 10
032 sees him much to her surprise she
recalls the brief time they spent time
together and asks him what he is doing
this for her even though she has as many
Replacements as needed Toma tells her to
shut up and says that the reason he is
here is to save her because there is
only one of her in this world
accelerator Rambles on how Toma is
acting like a hero with the lines he
said to her and seems to have forgotten
of his presence Toma tries to punch him
however accelerator simply Taps his feet
on the ground creating an explosion of
rock and dirt throwing Tomah a few feet
away from accelerator accelerator mocks
Tomah for being slow and proceeds to tap
on the medal of railways the metal began
to distort and bend towards Toma though
he Dodges it suddenly accelerator begins
throwing several metal rails towards him
the scenery is engulfed by smokes of
dirt and dust caused by the rails
hitting the ground the Smoke Clears with
Tomah in the middle of the Rails
seemingly unhurt by accelerator's
attacks he looks up and suddenly sees
several metal beams Falling Towards him
it hits the ground causing dirt and dust
to be displaced into the air covering
Toma from accelerator and misaka 10
032's view he looks up and sees
accelerator standing on top of one of
the metal beams mocking Toma for his
lack of speed they stare down each other
for a while before accelerator goes down
on the ground
he Taps the ground again displacing dirt
and rock on Thomas person Tomah falls to
the ground to which accelerator proceed
to walk towards him he raises his hand
indicating that he will end Tomah by
touching him
with a hand coming closer Tomah slaps it
away with his right hand for a few
seconds there is silent air between them
with accelerator being unable to
comprehend the situation suddenly
accelerator screams and Stomps the
ground is placing Rock and dirt into the
air and injuring Toma accelerator tries
to kick Toma but he Dodges it before his
kick can connect Tomah recovers and
slowly inches away from the wreckage he
sees accelerator walking towards him
saying that the containers seem to have
contained wheat flour in them and also
comments that it would be dangerous
since there is no wind tonight he quits
what would happen if the powdery flower
floating in the air would catch fire and
asks Tomah if he knows what dust
explosions are
realizing what's going to happen Tomah
makes a run for it while accelerator
laughs a part of the cargo holding area
is engulfing Flames as an ignition is
set off and making the flower explode
Tomah survives the dust explosion caused
by accelerator whose uninjured and
comments on how they almost killed
himself as the oxygen was used in the
dust explosion he caused accelerator
comments on how Toma should rejoice as
he is the first one to have pushed
accelerator into a near-death situation
Tomah does not respond and only pulls
himself up to confront accelerator once
again
accelerator gloats on how no matter what
Tomah does as he can control any Vector
he comes in contact with and with him
touching Toma he can blow up all these
veins and organs he keeps on gloating
saying that Tomah still being able stand
and breathe before him as he's somewhat
a miracle in order Toma stay down
already accelerator begins to charge
towards Tomah extending his right arm
trying to touch him with nothing left to
do Toma clenches his fist and attacks
accelerator of the puncher's jaw the
force of tomah's punch hurls accelerator
a few feet away from him
Tillman has surprised himself at what
happened and realizes that imagine
breaker works against accelerator
meanwhile accelerator struggles to get
up from tomah's punch and says that
Tomah made his blood jump for joy
however it was simply a facade by
accelerator as he charges towards Toma
again in an enraged state
Tomah successfully Dodges his advances
and punches him in the face Tomlin gives
several quick punches to accelerator's
face with accelerator being unable to
defend Tomah tries to connect another
punch however accelerator uses his
Vector powers to LEAP in a considerable
height and Retreat accelerator is
obviously shaken by Thomas punches and
tries to regain his balance and is
unable to comprehend what just happened
walks into accelerators pondering of his
situation and mocks in for his status of
being unbeatable Tomah says that since
accelerator deflects all attacks and
defeats his opponents in one attack he
would never know how to street fight
enraged by Tomas insults accelerator
uses his Vector powers to control the
metal on the railways they begin to
distort and bend carrying Tomah into the
air who is standing on the metal despite
this Tomi uses the medal propelling him
into to the air to deliver a punch to
accelerator sending him in to a stop
sign Tomah comes closer towards him and
asks him why those people Mikoto clones
who try to live their lives the best
they can end up being prey to him
accelerator who is sitting on the ground
laughs at whatoma said he stands up and
says that what Toma just said about
those people trying to live their lives
is all nonsense accelerator raises his
arms and began spouting strange clicking
and screeching noises from his mouth The
Sounds lead to his laughter and suddenly
gusts of wind fill the area they are on
the most notably streams of blue energy
begins to form above accelerator
squirreling and whirling above him
within his control accelerator says kill
him and the blue energy compresses into
a small sphere and then suddenly it
releases several streams of energy
towards Toma
who was overwhelmed by its power and is
blown away accelerator laughs at him and
begins to form another ball of energy he
tells Tomah that he is all talk and is
truly powerless against him and tells
him that he will finish him off with one
more hit however someone shouts his name
accelerator the konolas arrived and is
ready to fire her rail then towards him
Toma however asks Makoto to not do
anything Makoto smiles and apologizes to
Toma saying how Toma wished for nothing
to be lost and for everyone to be
smiling but that is impossible Dakota
continues by saying that she's about to
do is selfish however she just wants
Toma to live on Makoto prepares to fire
her signature attack however she
realizes that something is amiss we Coda
notices that the ball accelerator is
forming his plasma formed by controlling
the direction of air and compressing
them into one spot the sphere of plasma
is getting larger and larger by the
second and Makoto notes that her power
is unable to do anything suddenly Makoto
notices the wind and describes that
accelerator is calculating the flow of
wind to control the plasma Mikoto
suddenly hears the Mew of a certain cat
and sees that the cat is with an
unconscious mizaka 10032 and goes to her
side she asks mizaka 10 032 to wake up
because she needs her to do something
for her as she is the only who can do it
to protect homa's dream
misaka 10 032 is awakened by Makoto's
cries and stands up in the city the wind
turbines are moving on their own
producing powerful gusts of wind
meanwhile accelerator is losing his
control of the ball of plasma and asks
himself if he had miscalculated the flow
of the Winds back in the city several
Sparks are coming out of the nacelle of
the wind turbine accelerator realizes
that there shouldn't be any
miscalculations in his part and
discovers that the wind is being
produced artificially by directing
electric power on the motor of the wind
turbines to make spin
accelerator turns around and sees mizaka
10032 referring to her as the one who
tampered with the wind turbines in the
city several masaka clones are directing
their electric power onto the motor of
the wind turbines empowering them to
turn
accelerator is enraged by this and
threatens to kill misaka 10032 however
Makoto will rise to protect her filled
with contempt at this site accelerator
says that Makoto is too weak for him
even though they are both level five
suddenly tomah's voice calls out to
accelerator telling him to not touch
them as he slowly walks towards
accelerator the surprise at first
accelerator becomes excited saying that
Tomah is truly the best and charges
towards him he runs towards Toma
extending his hands they both reach the
point where they could touch each other
accelerator uses his hand to try and
touch Toma however he evades forcing
accelerator to use his other hand
however Tomah blocks his other hand as
well using his imagined breaker
accelerator is left with an opening
unable to defend himself fast enough
Tona prepares his stance and clenches
his fist
jumping towards accelerator he gives one
final punch to accelerator's face which
sends him rolling a few feet away from
Tomah and before the Makoto and mizaka
10032 tomat is seen sleeping in a
familiar Ward however he soon becomes
uneasy and wakes up he looks to see that
misaka 10 032's figure lose before him
holding his hand which is resting upon
her breasts surprised by this he asks
himself why such a happy event is
occuring to him as he does not remember
raising any flags for this moment at all
misaka 10 032 informs Tomah that he was
the one that grabbed her though she said
that she was the one who moved his hand
towards her breast as so she could
measure his heartbeat and brain waves
using the electric flow in his body much
to tomah's dismay since he cannot feel
that he is touching them due to the
anesthesia applied on him
coma says in relief that they somehow
both made out of the situation alive
Belle mizaka 10 000 in 32 states that
she cannot return to the world as of yet
even though the experiment with
accelerator has been suspended as her
body needs Readjustment as she was a
clone that was accelerated to growth she
says goodbye to Tomah carrying with a
black cat she brought into the ward with
her before leaving Toma asked mizaka
10032 if the readjustments would cure
her to which she replies that he does
need to worry as she will see him again
soon she leaves shortly thereafter the
next day Tomah receives an inspection
from the frog-faced doctor saying
there's nothing serious with his
condition he then says how Thomas he may
have affection to the particular room
that he's in to which Toma
half-heartedly laughs off
Toma then goes to sleep however he is
soon awoken by the arrival of Makoto who
came to visit him bringing with her a
gift from him
she tells him that the cookies she just
bought was the most expensive she can
find in a basement of a department store
before leaving Tomah says that if Makoto
hadn't given away her DNA map then the
sisters would have never been born it
continues on by saying that even though
the experiment was wrong their birth is
something she should be proud of Makoto
replies by saying that because of her
more than ten thousand of her clones
have been killed later midday Tomah is
all alone in his room sleeping soundly
Tomo opens his eyes into his horror a
girl wearing white robes on top of him
is index she asks Tomah if he has
anything to say though Toma is stricken
in fear he answers her promptly by
saying the word good morning predictably
index is angered by his words in a
familiar crunching soundness heard that
is later drowned by his scream index is
biting him and with Toma trying to plead
her saying that his injuries are serious
and that shouldn't she worry about him
the master of a house
hearing this index starts biting and
shouts that she was worried she hugs him
and repeats what she just said that she
was worried unable to do anything about
it Thomas says sorry to her index then
asks him what he fought for this time to
which Toma answers that he fought for
himself the scene later cuts to Makoto
smiling and walking back to her dorm
adornatory door is open to which Kuroko
greets her on izama and hugs her pairing
her face into Makoto's chest the scene
changes to mizaka 10 032 feeding her cat
misaka 10 032 brings the cat near her
face and it licks her face this
surprises her at first though in the end
it makes her smile the end be sure to
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
to not miss the next part
foreign